okay everyone I'm so excited today
because Eduardo Franco himself is back
on the show this time he's here to talk
about self-reliance which is on Hulu
Friday how you doing today
Eduardo good man how you doing man I'm
doing good it's good to see you again uh
I really love this film man you're
you're always doing great exciting stuff
so I see your name on something I want
to jump right in and uh I it was
interesting appreciate that oh of course
and it's interesting man because even in
the opening credit scene it's a Lonely
Island production
I'm imagine that's an immediate yes from
you right like did you look up to these
guys of course man that that stuff uh
that their stuff blew me away when I was
in high school it was it was uh just
just the most insane you know [__] to
see and hear but um it's like an honor
you know to be like attached to
something that's got that title in the
beginning you know what I mean and uh I
haven't been able to like actually get
to like work with you know any you know
like Samberg and stuff I did meet him
briefly but you know it's it's it's just
an honor to be within the within the the
circle of of of you know of these these
Giants man they're they're the best man
yeah and you rightfully deserve to be
there and it's interesting too because I
love your character you're playing here
is a a PA ninja um what side of that was
easier to tap into you for the uh PA
side or the ninja side yeah no dud yeah
shout out all the production assistants
man they they they work their ass off yo
and they and it's like sort of it's
funny PA ninja that's kind of what a PA
is man they're in the shadows you don't
really hear about them you don't really
know about them but they're out there
man there's a lot of them and they you
know they work their ass off so shout
out shout out all the PA ninjas out
there man but um dude it was it was uh
it was dope because Jake was just very
open with everything and and and uh we
tried it a couple ways man we tried
tried playing it a little bit goofier a
little bit like you know a little bit
funner like hey man we're big fans of
you you know in the scenes and stuff and
like that's how we're coming out of the
Shadows to like sort of talk to him but
uh but then the the version you do see
in in the uh in the film where it's like
a lot creepier that that's what that's
what
uh I love that that's what we landed
that's like that's what made you know
what I mean because I feel like when you
do take it sort of
serious in a comedy that makes it
funnier like naturally I feel and and
I'm I'm glad it is sort of resonating
with with with y'all because that's all
I could ever do is hope that it does pop
or does you know do its you know do its
what it's intended you know but uh but
uh yeah man it was it was a
collaborative effort man it was it was
Jake both acting and directing in the
scene at the same time
yeah yeah that that's cool and it and
that's a great point you made about
playing it serious for it to come off in
a better way comedically which it
definitely does uh and it's interesting
what you're wearing in this I like you
got the black turtleneck on so I I see
that and I just wonder like are you
dripping sweat on set all day in that
thing like do you get some air you pull
that thing down I can't remember if it
was hot or not I think no it was it was
actually because we were shooting like
at night so it was all right we were
inside the house but like
I can't remember dude I don't remember I
feel like I would have remembered if it
was really really hot and I was Dripping
because that's a very good very good
point that's a thing that you know a lot
of
people you don't notice it obviously on
camera but then like you know people
talk about it after oh dude it was so
hot it was terrible you know I was yeah
yeah yeah but no luckily it was also
just like just like uh it was like like
more like athletic wear I don't know how
you call that material but it was like
like breathable I guess it was it was uh
it was not it was it was actually very
it was probably the most comfortable
attire I've ever worn in any any project
maybe the most comfortable clothes I'll
ever wear in any sort of project you
know what I mean there yeah I mean when
I did books smart it was dope Olivia and
costumes allowed allowed me to to wear
like most of it was my clothes anyway so
that was pretty damn
comfortable uh but uh on this one yeah
that stuff I mean it was like pajamas it
was it was like sweat pants and and I
was wearing like Vans which is the shoe
that I wear all the time it was like it
was just like that it was just all black
it was dope yeah that must have been fun
too yeah and I'm glad to hear you
weren't like dying in that and uh it's
interesting man too just before this
interview and I Was preparing I Googled
Ardo Franco the first thing that comes
up now is why is Eduardo Franco's Hair
so long so it shows me that it's iconic
like a staple of you so are you fully
committed still or have you ever any
thoughts of like oh maybe I want to
change it one day are you Adit it I
don't uh as of right now there's no rush
you know I don't have any sort of
intentions to do that unless unless a
job comes along where it's like we we
you know there's a V for V for Vendetta
scene in it where where you have to you
know shave it Buzz It Off on camera
whatever then it's like the maybe you
know what I mean but but uh but other
than that right as of right now there is
no there is no uh talks of it and also
uh if and when the day were to come it's
definitely going to be like a sit down
and really discuss what's going on
because you know what I mean it's gotten
it's it's made its way into like the the
the stratosphere of of of you know the
the career and stuff and I mean no
shampoo commercials yet you feel me but
but hopefully sometime soon you know and
I love that that's that's like the thing
that pops why is his hair so long you
know what man the truth is it's
because when I decided to grow my hair
out I was just sick of getting haircuts
right and then uh because when you when
when I would like when I was a kid I had
like spiky hair that little Mexican kid
with like spiky gelled hair you know
what I mean and uh and so then you know
you'd get a haircut you'd have little
hairs everywhere so you'd have to take a
shower and I I hated having to do that
like like immediately after I'm like I
already showered this morning I got to
go shower afterwards this is ridiculous
and
then uh when I moved moved out of my mom
and dad's house when I was 19 uh
obviously I you know getting a haircut
would cost money and there was not a
that was not a priority so I just here
we are yeah yeah hell yeah dude looks
great uh it's iconic and you know as I'm
looking at you while you're doing this
interview I love the wall you have of
figures and that's leading to a question
I had I love the post you have on
Instagram like you had the cocaine
Michael Myers love that you saw that I
saw yeah so is that one is that the NECA
Michael Myers and is NECA your go-to
brand if so that's that's not the the
the the that's the mesco mesco Michael
Myers uh so it's it's cool because it
comes with like a what I like about
their figures is they're they're in like
the six inch scale and they they're uh
they have like all these soft goods you
know on them I love it when these these
action figures uh come with soft goods
like material you know what I mean like
their clothes and stuff feels real like
it's made out of cloth and stuff and I
don't I just feel like I'm living in
this like crazy fantasy right now of
like action figures being the greatest
that they've ever been you know and I I
don't just only stick to like licensed
stuff there's some unlicensed stuff out
there some third party stuff out there
that comes out that's real dope that uh
for legal reasons I'm not going to name
because I don't want it to go away so
yeah yeah there's some real good stuff
out there that's super fun to [__]
goof off with no it's impressive and and
I really love you had the collection
behind you very very cool um dude it's
this is nothing man this is the sound
proofing in the studio the sound
proofing yeah so I got so much junk
everywhere man it's too much too much
junk it's spilling out all over the
place no I love it um Before I Let You
Go water I just want to ask real quick
because it's on everyone's mind you
don't have to answer this but fans kind
of went to a panic uh with a cast photo
of day one of stranger things season
five now they're thinking you're not in
the season can you give us hopes that
you are and can you say anything if not
totally cool too no no worries I
appreciate that I'm it's it's it's uh
it's uh it's nice it's nice to hear that
there's there's some sort of uh you know
concern or something you know what I
mean but uh I've never I never got a
phone call so I think uh yeah I think
that's it oh okay well well miss maybe
there's still hope though I have I have
faith I appreciate that yeah yeah yeah
um well I can't wait for everyone to
check out Reliance on Hulu it's Friday
self-reliance Eduardo Franco kills it
and uh it's amazing so check it out it's
streaming and you get to see him play
apaa ninja Eduardo thank you so much for
joining me today man as usual and I hope
to have a great day and talk to you
again hell yeah dog thank you man